Salut ! Nous sommes samedi matin, il est 11H, c'est pour ça qu'ici dans ma fenêtre... il fait encore nuit !
Hier dans la vidéo je vous ai parlé de la prise de décision à pile ou face.
Aujourd'hui c'est différent puisque je vous apprends à bluffer quelqu'un ou du moins être encore plus performant dans vos arnaques avec vos amis.
Et ça je tenais à vous le dire, ce n'est pas beau.
On peut aller en enfer pour ça.
Donc c'est purement pour la culture générale, mais il existe une technique pour gagner à pile ou face !
Générique !
[musique]
Initialement, on pense que les chances sont équitables pour gagner à pile ou face.
C'est pile ou c'est face, donc c'est 50% ou 50%.
Easy !
Et c'est vrai, c'est complètement vrai !
Mais on peut changer la donne à notre avantage ! Je vous explique comment.
Un peu comme dans la vidéo sur le Chifoumi, dont je vous mets le lien ici,
si vous n'avez pas vu cette formidable production de Fabien Olicard du Mental Vlog.
Je vais vous donner tout un processus qui va vous permettre de faire ce jeu n'importe quand, en ayant un maximum de chances de votre coté.
Imaginez, vous êtes avec un ami, n'importe quoi, vous voulez lancer une partie de pile ou face et surtout vous voulez la gagner !
Hey oui tu m'étonnes !
La première chose à faire c'est que vous n'allez pas parier que sur pile ou que sur face.
Vous proposez une amélioration du jeu, et vous allez choisir chacun une séquence de 3 résultats.
Donc ça peut être: pile/pile/pile, pile/face/face, ou pile/face/pile...
En fait il y a 2 puissance 3 possiblités.
8 possibilités...
2 puissance 3.
C'est pareil...!
Ensuite on lance la pièce pleins de fois, comme le pile ou face classique quoi...
Et vous notez les résultats sur un bout de papier ou juste mentalement jusqu'à temps que l'une de vos deux séquences apparaissent.
Parfois ça peut sortir en 3 coups, parfois il va en falloir un dizaine, une douzaine de coups, avant que l'une des deux séquences pile/face/face, par exemple que vous auriez choisi, sorte.
Et c'est là qu'on atteint les limites de notre cerveau.
Parce qu'intuitivement on pense qu'on a les mêmes chances, que c'est un peu près équitable.
Et c'est complètement faux !
Les statistiques nous prouvent le contraire.
Alors rassurez vous, je ne vais pas vous faire la grosse démonstration mathématique qui va vous permettre de bien comprendre pourquoi les statistiques nous donne raison dans ces cas là.
Je vais vous donner le résultat final, applicable et gagnant.
Vous aurez ensuite en appliquant cette méthode, 3 chances sur 4 de gagner au jeu du pile ou face.
La première étape,
Et il n'y a que deux étapes, donc ça va... c'est tranquille !
La première étape je disais, c'est que c'est l'autre personne qui va commencer par choisir sa séquence.
Ensuite vous allez donner votre séquence de 3 résultats sur 3 lancés.
Sauf que votre réponse dépend directement de la séquence qu'il a choisi.
Est-ce que c'est bien clair ?!
Pas tellement ?
Explication plus précise !
Si votre adversaire choisi face/face/face...
Alors on va se donner un code on va dire "FFF".
Si il choisi FFF, vous vous choisissez PFF.
Pour Pile/Face/Face.
En faisant ça, vous aurez, écoutez moi bien...
7 chances sur 8 de gagner !
Si il choisi FFP, vous choisissez PFF.
Et là vous aurez quand même 3 chances sur 4 de gagner.
75% vis-à-vis des 50% de départ.
Si il prend FPF, vous prenez FFP.
Et je vous fais les 5 derniers plus rapidement et de toute manière je vous les mets dans la description.
Si il prend FPP vous prenez FFP. Si il prend PFF vous prenez PPF. Si il prend PFP vous prenez PPF également. Il prend PPF alors vous prenez FPP. 3 chances sur 4. Et enfin, si il prend PPP (pile/pile/pile) vous prenez FPP (face/pile/pile).
Et là c'est encore une fois 7 chances sur 8 de gagner.
Si vous voulez que je vous trouve un moyen mnémotechnique de retenir ça, ou que je vous donne des astuces pour vous faire une bidoche lorsque vous faites le jeu de manière un petit peu subtile,
vous me le dites dans les commentaires et je me ferai un plaisir de faire une suite à cette vidéo.
Quoi qu'il arrive si ça vous plait d'avoir ce genre de technique, vous pouvez me le faire savoir en laissant un délicat...
Pouce en l'air ! [chante]
du week-end, en plus il fait plaisir.
N'oubliez pas également de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir, puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour, du premier janvier au 31 décembre,
Donc rendez-vous demain à 11H, et ouais les mecs, le dimanche c'est à 11H !
Rendez-vous demain à 11H.
Ciao !
[musique du générique de fin]